sustainability is a you know really
broad scope of of dealing with with
conflict or with issues or challenges
that come across in the more developed
countries you know we'll look at how we
avoid abusing the environment and how we
can build buildings in a green
sustainable standards and we are very
advanced on that on that side but if you
go to Africa to countries you know like
Uganda and Nigeria and Ghana and if you
go to Central America you know the basic
needs of sustainability sometimes is to
teach the basic hygiene for for children
giving them a toothbrush and and and
explaining them how to cross the roads
for safety which is something that they
are not familiar because they live in
distant and rural era and working with
the community around what is important
for them as part of their sustainability
how they build the capabilities over
time whether again this is more of a
healthcare issues education around
topics and we embrace the environmental
issues into these these ideas but in a
very soft way so there is a big
difference for sustainability in the
developed or in the third-world
countries and in the developed world
we're doing this big water project in
the Bahamas it's a 90 million dollar
project on reducing water leakage in the
in the system over a 10-year period we
will reduce the water leakage from 50
percent to 25 percent and we've been
doing a lot of work around education of
people working with schools working with
children about the importance of water
about the importance of saving water
about creating the awareness of why
water are so crucial in our life why
clean
water are so crucial in our life this is
sustainability for these specific
citizens in this specific area of the
world so you can combine the message
according to what you do and according
to what the people on the ground needs
and these things being very successful
you can save a lot of money not only
water but a lot of money for these
schools and for these families if you
make and create the awareness and
education programs around